folks the time is upon us Counter-Strike
2 is real and it's common we finally now
have videos that show off the new engine
the new graphics and the new smokes and
my friends Italy is back baby nothing
will ever be the same I never thought
I'd really be able to say this but let's
talk about Counter-Strike too
[Music]
over the last three weeks The Source 2
hysteria has reached an all-time high
I'm serious people were losing their
minds about this and I think it
honestly should be studied one day but
with more credible leaks substantial
Data Mining and a ton of trolling from
the official CS go account than ever
before it actually felt like something
was coming we didn't know when we didn't
know what but we knew something had to
be in the works and as of yesterday well
we finally have a lot more information
all right everyone slow down and take a
deep breath we have a lot to go over so
what the hell is Counter-Strike 2. the
developers have described it as both a
complete overhaul and upgrade to
everything in CS go from Graphics to
gameplay mechanics this is not just a
facelift we also know it's going to be
free to play just like CS go is and will
be dropping sometime this summer for the
time being CS go and Counter-Strike 2
will remain two separate games but
there's been no confirmation on whether
or not CS2 will eventually overtake CS
go completely what has been confirmed is
that the majority of your CS go account
will carry over to the new game meaning
all of your lovely skins will be safe
and graphically updated however this
also means that not only vac bands will
carry over but matchmaking cooldowns as
well so everyone better be on their best
behavior if they want to play this
anytime soon but I'm a good boy with
shitty skin so I don't really care about
that what I do care about is what the
the game's actually going to look
and feel like well on top of valve
dropping the announcement they also
released three videos showcasing some of
the biggest changes coming to the game
well let's start with the maps we which
can be split into three categories some
maps like Mirage and dust have been
graphically overhauled but mostly
untouched others like Nuke have been
upgraded to feature the new Dynamic
lighting system and finally older Maps
like overpass and more importantly Italy
have been completely redone but I'd
argue that the biggest standout from
these videos is just how different the
lighting looks now visibility seems to
be improved tenfold thank you valve
there are now Reflections on the goddamn
floor and just look at that
water
but that being said the game does look a
hell of a lot different now and it's
going to be interesting to see who likes
the new polish style now in another
video valve explains their new approach
to server tick rate instead of having 64
or 128 tick servers Counter-Strike 2
will have sub-tick updates meaning that
your inputs can now be registered in
between ticks rather than just at each
tick did they explain how they do this
absolutely not but on paper this change
would be revolutionary to the game
hypothetically if this new system works
as intended we'll be getting a much
smoother more reactive experience where
we can trust that we are getting a fair
outcome in our fire fights now CS go
also released one more video one that is
likely the most controversial update to
CS2 the smoke grenades okay that's
awesome that's like
this is like some Valor and right
here that's dope in CS go you throw a
smoke it bounces a bit it plumes and
then sits there for 18 seconds now
smokes are much more Dynamic so not only
do they mutate to the environment
instead of clipping through objects they
can be shot through and dissipated for a
period of Time With Grenades for
non-counter strike fans having an entire
video dedicated to how the smoke
grenades work seems a bit odd but smokes
are such an integral part of
Counter-Strike and a change like this is
going to completely alter how the game
is played smoke
Jordan that's how you doing baby baby
next to those three massive changes
valve has also shown off some of the
other updates that are coming to
Counter-Strike 2. visual effects like
blood and utility have been upgraded to
be much more Dynamic the UI has gotten
an overhaul as well as including this
neat little deck of cards thingy for
kill counters don't say valve never
stole anything from valorent and finally
the audio has been reworked to be more
balanced and quote better reflect the
physical environment be more distinct
and express more game state
all right this is where we get to the
all-important question how and when do
we get to play well valve has explained
that Counter-Strike 2 is in its Limited
Test meaning that certain players will
get access at different times leading up
to its full release that being said some
lucky community members were invited to
play this thing before its actual
announcement it was me
Forest
uh machine
Harry Hugo uh sponge Moses and then two
people that play matchmaking with one of
the devs but in regards to actually
getting access to this Limited Test
valve had this to say players are
selected based on a number of factors
deemed important by the Counter-Strike 2
development team including but not
limited to recent Play Time on valve
official servers trust factor and steam
account standing I bet he feels stupid
now having flamed all those people in
your silver 2 lobbies as for what's
actually available in The Limited Test
it's currently just deathmatch and
unranked competitive on Dust 2 only but
valve has said that more content will be
coming out as the test continues in
light of this recent news the Cs go
community and The Gaming Community at
large has lost their minds
mostly trying to get into the Beta
itself seriously I've been opening and
closing the client every goddamn five
minutes waiting for invite
I don't think it's coming now regardless
of my pain a ton of pros and content
creators have gotten access to the
Limited Test and have been weighing in
with their initial thoughts on how the
game actually feels now obviously you
won't be able to come to your own
conclusions until you actually try it
yourself but for the time being those
who have tried it seem to be pretty
goddamn excited if you throw a Hachi
into it you can clear the smoke
temporarily with an aide
surprises yeah yeah I swear to God
I can show you man
we're not trolling you
yeah
when you shoot this hole CS go came out
like 11 years ago and it defined an
entire generation of Gamers and just
like its predecessors its impact on the
gaming industry is hard to qualify
and that's why it's just so crazy to
think that it's actually kind of coming
to an end in a way but
I couldn't be more excited for the
future because this isn't just the next
evolution of Counter-Strike this is an
entirely new chapter for Shooters
Esports and gaming all together
[Music]
some launching a client can we do it
please Gaben
Mr Gaben
Mr Gaben nope one more time
one more time why not one more time
surely surely 10 seconds later right
nothing